today on the matt walsh show is our
society experiencing an epidemic of mass
psychosis the regime fact checkers say
no but we'll look at the evidence today
also police officers in california pull
a man from a crashed plane minutes
before it it's hit by a train sounds
like something out of an action movie
but it happened in real life should we
still defund the police and for months
we were told that it's dangerous
misinformation to claim that the vaccine
interferes with a woman's menstrual
cycle but yet again what was once
misinformation has been vindicated by
the evidence plus navy boot camp will
now include anti-racism training and our
daily cancellation will cancel the la
times columnist who argue that it's our
humanitarian duty to mock unvaccinated
people when they die of covet we'll talk
about all that much more today on the
matt walsh show
[Music]
you know it's really important that you
don't as they say put all your eggs in
one basket you have to diversify your
investments and especially now with
inflation at 40-year highs and it's here
to stay because here's the dirty little
secret from the government that they
don't want you to know uh they want it
they want the inflation right now
inflation rates are higher than the
interest on treasury bonds so with every
day that passes the government owes less
on its mountain of debt
so you got to protect your savings now
hedge against inflation with gold from
birch gold because the government is
sabotaging the value of the us dollar
birch gold will help you convert an
eligible ira or 401k into an ira backed
by real gold uh that's peace of mind
that's what you're getting and you're
also getting a great investment that's
why i am a birch gold customer i
encourage you to be one as well with
thousands of satisfied customers and an
a plus rating with a better business
bureau you can trust birch gold to
protect your savings text walsh to 98 98
98 to get a free info kit on holding
gold in a tax sheltered account then
call birch and protect your hard-earned
savings again that's walsh to 98 98.98
now to get your free kit now
you know one of the most consistent
features of our age is that correct
ideas are often confirmed by the people
who try to debunk them so if you want to
know which ideas are not only right but
the most important and relevant to your
life all you have to do is look for the
ones that the so-called experts and
self-proclaimed fact checkers are most
vehemently denying you can almost
appreciate the symmetry and simplicity
of it all the things you should believe
are the things they're telling you not
to believe and trying to punish you for
believing and that brings us to a term
that entered the public conscious a
couple of weeks ago and which the
cultural powers that be have been trying
to remove from our conscience ever since
and that is mass formation psychosis now
this term did not originate with joe
rogan's interview of dr robert malone
malone himself did not coin it
but he's probably responsible for
introducing most people to the concept
during the widely listened to discussion
on rogan's podcast last week dr malone
argued that covet hysteria among the
public could be an example of a kind of
mass psychosis event
was from
basically european intellectual inquiry
into what the heck happened in germany
in the 20s and 30s you know very
intelligent highly educated population
and they went barking mad
and how did that happen
the answer is mass formation psychosis
when you have a society that has become
decoupled from each other and has
free-floating anxiety
in a sense that things don't make sense
we can't understand it
and then their attention gets focused by
a leader or series of events on one
small point just like hypnosis
they
literally become hypnotized and can be
led anywhere
and one of the aspects of that phenomena
is the people that they identify as
their leaders the ones typically that
come in and say you have this pain and i
can solve it for you i and i alone okay
can fix this problem for you okay then
they will lead they will follow that
person through it doesn't matter whether
they lie to them or whatever the data
are irrelevant and furthermore anybody
who questions that narrative is to be
immediately attacked they are the other
this is central to mass formation
psychosis
and this is what has happened
we had all those conditions if you
remember back before
2019 everybody was complaining the world
doesn't make sense blah blah blah
and we're all isolated from each other
we're all on our little tools
we're not connected socially anymore
except through social media um
and then this thing happened and
everybody focused on it
that is how mass formation psychosis
happens and that is what's happened here
now as if to prove the point shortly
after the interview aired youtube and
twitter began removing the clips
mentioning mass formation psychosis for
a time if you search the term on google
it return no results when's the last
time that happened
for anything on google instead the
search would return a note from google
letting you know that it's looking for
reliable sources on the subject and it
will update the search results once
those sources are located didn't take
long for the reliable sources to come
along in the form of articles from mass
media outlets debunking the concept but
before we get to the alleged debunking
we should note that malone's interview
was not the first time even recently
when the subject of mass formation
psychosis was broached on joe rogan's
show a short time before that dr peter
mccullough
brought up the same subject and went
into more detail describing the
conditions necessary for this phenomenon
to occur we're in what's called a mass
formation psychosis this is very
important
i give credit to dr matthias desmond in
the university of ghent in belgium and
recently dr mark mcdonald psychiatrist
from l.a mark mcdonald's got a new book
out the united states of fear describing
how the mass psychosis developed what
your listeners need to know is a mass
psychosis is when there is a group think
that develops that's so strong that it
leads to something horrific and the
examples are these mass suicides that
occur in these religious cults the
example is nazi germany when people walk
into gas chambers and we're guests these
horrific things in four elements here is
very important joe first there must be a
period of prolonged isolation lockdowns
number two there must be a withdrawal of
things taken away from people that they
used to enjoy that's happened number
three there must be constant incessant
free floating anxiety all this new cycle
all the the deaths and the
hospitalizations more more variant
mutant strains everything people can be
coming scared over and over again
and the last thing number four the
capper the capper is there must be a
single solution offered by an entity in
authority
and in this case is clear worldwide the
solution was
vaccination don't listen to any of that
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain it's all untrue it's
misinformation
google found its reliable sources which
is why a search of the term will now
pull up headlines like this
quote so-called mass formation psychosis
does not exist despite what you might
have heard on joe rogan
and quote an anti-vac scientist said
mass formation psychosis caused people
to follow cove 19 measures psychologists
say there's no such thing
and quote joe rogan mass formation
psychosis and why people really believe
unscientific things
and of course fact check no evidence of
pandemic mass formation psychosis say
experts speaking to reuters
those are the first four headlines that
come up in the search results
if you take the time to read the
articles in search of the apparently
ample amounts of evidence that this
phenomenon does not exist here's what
you'll find
on the independent reports quote
psychology experts have explained that
there is no evidence whatsoever to show
that a theory aired on joe rogan's
podcast about people believing in
mainstream ideas around covet is true
j van bavel an assistant professor of
psychology at uh new york university was
among many professors of psychology and
neurological science to debunk a concept
called mass formation psychosis quote to
my knowledge there's no evidence
whatsoever that this concept is true he
told the associated press on sunday or
rather saturday
and then we have reuters there they're
chiming in and says mass formation
psychosis is not an academic term
recognized in the field of psychology
nor is there evidence of any such
phenomenon occurring during the
covenanting pandemic multiple experts in
crowd psychology have told reuters the
phrase does not appear in the american
psychological association dictionary of
psychology nor does it appear in the
psycnet database of published research
articles numerous psychologists have
also told reuters that such a condition
is not officially recognized i've never
heard of this concept john drury
professor of social psychology and
director of research and knowledge
exchange at the university of sussex
wrote in an email to reuters j van bavel
associate professor of psychology and
neuroscience at new york university said
the term doesn't exist as a real
academic concept
and then business insider confirms quote
psychology experts told the associated
press there's no actual support for
malone's claims the term mass formation
psychosis does not even show up in the
american psychological association's
dictionary of psychology
quote to my knowledge there's no
evidence whatsoever for this concept j
van bavel an assistant professor of
psychology and neuroscience at new york
university told the ap also in the uk
john drury
his social psychologist at the
university of sussex told the ap the
idea of mass formation psychosis is
similar to mob mentality or the idea
that people in group in a group will
lose self-control and their identities
concepts he said have been discredited
by decades of research
now note how they debunk the concept
through appeals to a handful of alleged
authorities and always the same
authority so all these articles are
saying that so many psychologists have
said that this doesn't exist and then
they all tell us about one guy jay van
bael
he really seems to get around i have no
idea who he is he's just some assistant
professor of psychology in new york and
yet this random guy is quoted as a
definitive authority in literally all of
google's top search results on the
subject
some dude named john drury earns
multiple mentions as well and of course
the american psychological association
they all are quite positive that mass
psychosis does not exist
which is probably the first time that
any of these people have ever shown any
skepticism about any mental illness
or you know mental phenomenon
because it's due to the work of the
american psychological association and
guys like j van bavel
that we now have millions of boys in
school diagnosed as mentally ill because
they get bored during math class
i mean these people and their ilk are
why huge swaths of the american public
are addicted to psychotropic medication
they have medicalized and diseaseified
almost every aspect of the human
condition every personality trait every
difficult emotion every inconvenient
compulsion or behavior
and now they finally discover restraint
and skepticism about a psychological
concept
because it was mentioned on joe rogan's
show
this is why the experts
quote unquote especially the alleged
psychological and psychiatric experts
can be totally and absolutely dismissed
and i don't just mean about this subject
i mean in general
i don't care what any of these people
say about anything
because most of what they do has no
scientific basis
you know they makes they make
philosophical judgments about the human
condition they determine
how humans are supposed to think what
they're supposed to do
how they're supposed to be
and then they medicalize everything that
falls outside of the norms they've
determined but why should anyone care
about their philosophical judgments who
appointed them experts on the human
condition
and why should we trust their
appointments
these are questions that are never
answered
now
what about mass formation psychosis
we know what google and google's
appointed mental health experts have to
say but what is the reality
well we know that psychosis occurs when
people lose contact with reality that's
the definition it's an extreme
disconnect from reality that's that's
what psychosis is
and we know that this certainly happens
on an individual level nobody denies
that
the only question is is it possible for
it to happen on a larger scale
can entire populations or huge portions
of a population lose contact with
reality all at once and in the same way
well the answer is obviously yes
before we examine whether this is
happening today there's no question that
it does happen it has happened
therefore it can happen
you could call the phenomenon whatever
you want to call it mass formation
psychosis is just a label for it a fine
label a little bit too medicalized for
my taste but you know it's fine whatever
label you go with it's clear that the
phenomenon it describes is real
cults
as mentioned mass suicides
witch hunts
these are just a few obvious historical
examples
dr mccullough identifies four conditions
necessary to bring this about one is
isolation
then despair
then anxiety or fear then an authority
figure offering a solution
again call that whatever you want but it
is not debatable that historically these
factors have come together to produce
these kinds of results being described
as mentioned in the clips nazi germany
would seem to be an appropriate example
now is this what's happening with kovid
well just look at the results
might we say that there's been a
disconnect from reality when a mother
locks her teenage son in the trunk of
her car because she doesn't want to
he does she doesn't want him to give her
coved
what about the people triple vaxxed
who walk around outside with masks on
what about the masked woman i saw a few
months ago walking past us while we were
hiking in the mountains in the woods
she's by herself
in the woods with a mask on
is that nice is that not psychotic
behavior is that not a disconnect from
reality
people were people wearing masks alone
in their cars
what about those who've cut themselves
off from society locked themselves in
their homes for two years isolated
themselves and their children
for fear of a virus that poses almost no
significant threat to the vast majority
of healthy people
is there a disconnect from reality when
people push for mandated vaccines
even though the vaccines don't even stop
the spread of the virus
yes it's exceedingly clear that the mass
amounts of people have lost contact with
reality
they are at this point incapable of
seeing reality or being reasoned with
and their behavior if viewed objectively
is psychotic
everybody would have agreed prior to
last year that a healthy person who
wears a medical mask all day every day
is psychotic
i mean we would have all seen that as
paranoid ocd
behavior
many might view it differently now but
that's only further proof proof of the
mass psychosis itself
in fact
i would take it one step further
because i think we live in
an era
of mass psychosis
and it didn't begin with covid
even if let's pretend china had never
invented the virus and set it loose on
the globe
even if that never happened we could
still talk about mass formation
psychosis because we would still live in
a society where for example
millions of people in the span of just a
few years came to believe that men can
have babies
and millions more were coerced into
pretending they believe it even if they
don't
one delusional belief after another
enters our culture and spreads with
rapid efficiency often infecting the
younger generations first and foremost
why is that well because the internet
for one thing
is a pipeline for psychosis
it not only spreads the psychotic ideas
but but because it's addictive
it takes over people's lives it isolates
them from the real world
everyone you see walking around with
their heads buried in their phone all
the time everywhere they don't know how
to sit
you know in a chair for more than 30
seconds without looking at their phone
these are isolated people they have
isolated themselves
in cyberspace
thus fulfilling one of the necessary
conditions for mass psychosis
there's other kinds of isolation too by
the way
there's a very real effort
in our culture
by the powers that be especially in the
education system the government
to isolate children from their parents
to sever their ties with their family
you know to break down the
heteronormative
uh patriarchal family structure as blm
has has declared it wants to do
that's that is another hallmark of cults
that's what cults do
you know you start getting involved in a
cult and one of the first things they do
is they turn you against your family
for pretty obvious reason they can't
have you connected to anybody else they
need
you to be totally invested in their
world and their reality that they are
constructing for you
you cannot have any contact
you can't have a foot still in any other
world
but their world
and you know given that there has been a
generalized loss of meaning in our
society as materialism and nihilism
become the dominant philosophies of the
day
the conditions of both despair and
anxiety are also met
as for an authority figure offering a
solution there's no shortage of those
all of the teenage girls taking hormone
pills and dropping chopping their
breasts off
are relying on solutions presented to
them by the authority figures they trust
and those authority figures might just
be like social media influencers but
for them that's an authority
so we are a society which has severed
itself from reality
and from truth
and now which floats untethered in the
ether
we are preconditioned for one mass
psychotic episode after another
right now it's covet hysteria eventually
it'll be something else
there's no limit there's no floor
we are in an intellectual and moral
freefall
plunging infinitely
into the abyss
so
happy new year
now let's get to our five headlines
well gas prices at least around my neck
of the woods are still climbing and
there's no sign of them uh of going in
the other direction anytime soon which
is why if you have not gotten
the new app get upside now is your
chance to do it my listeners uh who have
taken advantage of get upside are making
up to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up all you got to
do is download the free get upside app
again it is free in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
well should get a bonus 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up that's up
to 50 cents cash back
and uh 25 cents per gallon after that
don't pay full price at the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside all you
got to do is download the app for free
and use promo code walsh you get up to
50 cents a gallon cash back on your
first tank some people who drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash back and
there's no catch there's no red tape the
cash is added to your account as simple
as that you can cash out any time to
your bank account paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands as well
just download the free get upside app
and use promo code walsh to get up to 50
cents a gallon cashback on your first
tank that's code walsh
uh you know i'm going through i gotta i
gotta just
mention this really briefly so i think
it's important for everybody to know i'm
going through a difficult time here at
work i don't mean to bring office drama
out in the open like this but i have to
say we recently changed studios we we
just moved to a different uh a different
room in the building
but somehow during that switch i lost
my chair or rather my chair was
appropriated it was stolen
my x-chair very comfortable chair it has
heating and massage capabilities i've
talked about it before
uh it's nowhere to be found i've looked
everywhere for it
i've checked every desk in the building
i've asked around
and the worst thing is when i ask
somebody do you know where my chair is
they like they look at me like this is
some kind of unimportant problem as if
they have more pressing concerns than
finding my chair
i asked my producer mckenna yesterday if
she goes with the chair and she says you
can ask around but then three hours
later
i don't mean to call her out but i saw
her sitting at her desk working on
something else and i still didn't have
my chair so there's a real problem with
priorities i think around here here's
here's the point you cannot take a man's
chair from him because a man forms a
special bond with his chair becomes part
of him
especially if that man is a lazy fat ass
like myself i feel out of pla i feel
disoriented now disturbed and i know
exactly i'll tell you exactly what's
happening
somebody took the chair
and they're hiding it until the heat is
off right until they think the coast is
clear and then they're gonna start
sitting in the chair but i'll tell you
i'm never gonna forget
i will find my chair one way or another
i promise you that
okay what do we talk about first uh
here's nancy pelosi
here's another really important subject
she's uh still milking this january 6th
thing and um
and and she says that you know there's
january 6th the the actual event but
then there's a sort of legislative
january 6th which the republicans are
engaging in by not doing exactly what
she wants them to do all the time so
let's listen
what the republicans are doing across
the country is really a a legislative
continue continuation of what they did
on january 6 which is to undermine
our democracy to uh undermine the
integrity of our elections uh to
undermine the uh
the voting power which is the essence of
a democracy
i think uh
those eyebrows are basically that that's
january 6th all over again
those eyebrows are a bigger tragedy than
january 6 actually
uh wha why i'm gonna
totally put aside everything she just
said because who cares
i i don't understand why people do this
why do you know especially like shallow
older women not all not all older but
but shallow ones like nancy pelosi
they seem to think that looking
perpetually surprised is somehow a good
substitute for looking young
because when you do that with the fake
eyebrows and the botox and everything
that's all you accomplish you just you
look like
like
uh someone just jumped out of the the
closet naked right in front of you
perpetually that's what that's always
the expression on your on your face
which is not the same thing as looking
younger here's an idea for you
just and i i say this to men and women
because but both both sexes are guilty
in different ways
when you get just look old it's okay to
look old when you're old because you are
it's not a secret everybody knows that
everyone knows that nancy pelosi
is 152 years old we all we're all aware
of that
so embrace it
age with dignity
this is all part you know this is all
this it's there's many things going on
here part of it is the um
are still our fear of death our refusal
to acknowledge our own mortality
and that makes it so people are somehow
embarrassed
to be older
and so they'll do whatever they can
they can't make themselves look young
but they can look like barely even human
now so yeah i'll look like some sort of
lizard creature and that's better than
looking like an old human
it's not just look like an old person
that's fine
that's why i don't i don't go along with
this stupid thing we do in in our
culture where it's embarrassed you're
not supposed to ask somebody their age
i do that all the time i think it's an
interesting fact to know about someone
i'll say how old are you
and usually especially my wife's with me
she'll she'll go elbow me don't ask that
why not how's it embarrassing
so if you're let's say 72 years old it's
it's you're embarrassed that you've been
on earth for 72 years
if anything younger people should be
embarrassed
that they haven't been around that long
that they're still new around here
they're newbies that should be the
embarrassing thing if anything you
should be lying to say that you're older
than you really are
i don't get it anyway uh let's move on
to this from usa today
officers in california
saved a pilot who crashed onto the
railroad tracks seconds before a train
smashed the wreckage into pieces
on sunday a cessna
172 made an emergency landing around 2pm
shortly after takeoff from whiteman
airport according to the associated
press and then landed right on the train
tracks as a train was coming two
officers from the la police department
can be seen on body camera footage
pulling the bloody pilot to safety
moments before the train collided with
the aircraft
that is not an overly dramatic
description that's actually what
happened we have the footage here let's
watch uh this footage real quick
okay so you can see them
this guy's right on the plane train
tracks
yeah it looks like four officers there
they're taking their lives into their
hands because
and then
[Music]
there you go so i think you can count
about five seconds
that is something right out of a movie
right there you count about five seconds
they had
and they could have still
you know even clearing it after five
seconds it could have been debris that
they hit them or anything so they were
taking their lives in their hands
to save a complete stranger
and i think that's it's it's worth
pointing to this video for i think three
reasons number one it's just an
incredible video
uh number two this is a great example of
actual heroism in a culture where
the term heroism you know heroic
courageous all these terms are so often
misused and abused and misappropriated
and uh we use it to describe
um
you know a a teacher who comes out as
non-binary to her sixth grade
students that's always heroic
no
that's
creepy this is actually what heroism
looks like
you're making a sacrifice number one
um
and you're putting yourself
in danger in some kind of danger doesn't
always have to be physical danger to be
heroic could be you know you could be
taking uh you know intellectual risks or
it could be something like that but
you're taking a real risk for the sake
of someone else that's what courage and
heroism looks like
and the third reason to bring it up is
um you look at that video and you say is
so are we still defunding the police is
that still an idea
we're gonna send the social workers in
to do that
when's the last time you met a social
worker who would do that
a team of uh social workers guidance
counselors therapists
i'll tell you what we defund the police
and we send the uh the squad of
therapists and guidance counselors in
they're going to stand off at a safe
distance
and counsel that guy in the plane
so that he feels better about the fact
that he's about to get pancaked by a
train
so they're going to provide him mental
they're going to focus on uh on
you know helping him in his mental
health
in the five seconds before he dies
now the reason you need cops is that you
need actual people to go into these
situations
and do what uh
most people are not willing to do
all right let's move to this for months
we've been told that there's no evidence
that the vaccine
interferes with the uh with the the
menstrual cycles of women
or of men
because men and women both got menstrual
cycles i'm told
at least i have to think that in order
to be on twitter
so uh here's just an example here's good
morning america this is from several
weeks ago i don't know exactly when it's
from but they they were talking about
this this claim that the vaccines might
interfere with menstrual cycles and they
said ah it's all misinformation it's not
true listen
we're going to turn now to our dr jenn
ashton who has some answers to some of
your more pressing medical questions
we'll start with the first one dr jen is
there a relationship between the
vaccines and menstrual cycles we've
definitely talked about we sure have you
guys and this is really spreading like
wildfire on social media with zero
scientific or medical basis for this
remember in medicine every time we talk
about a study of finding what is the
first thing we say big difference
between association
and causation so yes women can get the
vaccine and then experience changes in
their menstrual cycle that does not mean
that one causes the other and in fact if
you look at the biology of how these
vaccines work there is
zero hormonal interaction so please
let's put that to rest yes that's got a
lot of attention because a school
actually in florida was telling teachers
yeah that they used sight of this as a
reason for not being vaccinated defy
science so always good to repeat thank
you doc and another one here
by the way i think i just found my chair
it's right over there
oh okay
anyway
what uh so what you just heard there it
was all misinformation there's no
effect on the menstrual cycle there's no
evidence for it
that was then this is now
new york times new york times this week
a couple days ago this is the article
shortly after chronovirus vaccines were
rolled out about a year ago women
started reporting erratic menstrual
cycles after receiving the shots
some said their periods were late others
reported heavier bleeding than usual or
painful bleeding
there's already some transphobia here i
mean in this new york times article
they're they're saying women were
reporting erratic menstrual cycles
so i'm personally offended by that but
we'll try to just
go through it anyway
some postmenopausal women who hadn't had
a period in years even said that they
started menstruating again a study
published on thursday found that women's
menstrual cycles did indeed change
following vaccination against the
coronavirus the authors reported that
women who were inoculated inoculated had
slightly longer menstrual cycles after
receiving the vaccine than those who
were not vaccinated
well there you go
are we going to go back now and remove
all of those clips online and all the
articles and everything claiming that
there is not true it's misinformation of
course not
now
the articles that are admitting this now
they hasten to add that well it's only
slight changes it's temporary there's no
long-term harm
which might or might not be true but the
problem is number one how could you
possibly know that number two yeah but
you told us before that there was no
change
and now you say well there's a change
but it's only slight and temporary
how do we know that uh six months from
now it's not going to be oh gee actually
some of that sometimes it could cause
long-term lifelong problems
how do we know
you have no credibility we can't trust
anything you say
but we know why they were desperate to
shut all this kind of stuff down because
i mean if you're admitting
that there are any side effects at all
that there are any potential
complications even my let's say for the
sake of argument that these are only
minor complications
and that the changes to menstrual cycle
are temporary and uh and that's it
let's say that's true for the sake of
argument which again we can't possibly
know that right now
but even so
that is a that still qualifies as a a
complication a side effect
and what that means is that um now there
are when deciding whether or not to get
the vaccine
there are actual
factors you have to weigh it's not all a
fantasy this is not all
this is not just people q anon
conspiracy theorists
who are picking things up from facebook
memes
no totally reasonable people who are
aware of the evidence and the science
now have
factors to weigh
then you start doing calculations if
you're a woman
and you say hmm
the vaccine
doesn't really stop the spread of the
virus i can still contract it uh you
know i'm young and healthy
there there's there's
very
very little risk to me already from the
virus especially now with the omnicorn
going around and that's mild for almost
everybody
and on the other hand it affects my
menstrual cycle and we don't know a lot
about that and they just they just
admitted to it
yesterday so who knows what else is
going on
now you gotta weigh all these things
maybe you decide to still get the
vaccine but it
it would be perfectly reasonable and
rational to say hey
i don't know if it's worth the risk
it's just they cannot the regime cannot
admit
that there's any rational
thought process like that for people who
are hesitant about the vaccine
the whole narrative falls apart unless
they're all painted as a bunch of wacky
conspiracy theorists
meanwhile the ceo of pfizer uh made some
admissions himself about the vaccine
again this is the ceo of pfizer
and let's listen to his anti-vaxx
extremism
uh and we know that
the three the two dose of a vaccine
offer very limited protection if any the
three doses with a booster
the author reasonable protection against
hospitalization and deaths
in again there's nothing very good
um
and
less protection against the infection
now
we are working on a new version of our
vaccine the 1.1 let me put it that way
that will cover omicron as well
and
of course
we are waiting to have the final results
the vaccine will be ready in march
huh
two doses is
not enough it's not gonna do anything
doesn't stop the spread i mean these are
all things that by now we've heard we've
heard many times but this is the it just
just
it it cannot be emphasized enough that
you now have the ceo of pfizer saying
things that not but three weeks ago
would have got you banned from youtube
and twitter and maybe it still will if
you're not you know if you're not an
approved person
making these exact same statements all
right before we get to the comments i
have to i've mentioned it now in the
opening twice so i have to actually
talk about it a little bit from the
daily mail
it says training goes woke boot camp for
the navy to include classes on suicide
prevention hazing racism and sexual
assault after numerous crisis over the
past number of years
so us navy said it would expand its
eight-week boot camp program to include
two more weeks of classes focusing on
suicide prevention sexual assault hazing
and racism
the change the first major overhaul in
nearly 20 years comes as the navy
grapples with major
issues aboard the ships over the years
that include failures to address sexual
assaults fires and deadly collisions and
the rise of extremism within the ranks
um
uh rear admiral jennifer couture who
heads the naval service training command
told the associated press that the two
extra weeks of classes would reinforce
the behavior desired in a u.s naval
officer
she said quote we're telling our
recruits here are all the things that we
expect you to do and here's how we
expect you to behave and act she said
adding that it involves treating people
with respect and holding peers
accountable
so this is navy boot camp now
teaching about racism
treating people with respect
um
the kind of thing that you would get
from a from a guidance counselor
you know
and now this is this is what we're doing
in the military
you know i guess i'm old school and
old-fashioned and uh i still believe
at least for me
um as a as a citizen in the united
states relying on the military to
protect us
the only thing i care about for people
in the military
is that they're very good at killing the
bad guys
that is really it
at least if i were to make a list
of the qualities that i would think are
the most important
that's number one two three four and
five
and then maybe we could list a couple
things underneath that but that's that's
that's the top five right there good at
killing the bad guys
and then when you find out about
the chaos aboard these ships
collisions fires and they're telling us
themselves this is happening more often
now than it used to
might that be because
we are not emphasizing
skill
as much as we used to
of course that's it
but their way of solving that problem is
to do more of the thing that caused the
problem in the first place
all right let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
you know with all of the uh the car
makes and models out there it's
impossible to stock all the parts you
need in a traditional chain storefront
but why endure
all of that the pointless and seemingly
intimidating questions about the
specifications of your vehicle only to
have the person by the counter order the
parts on this computer anyway you have
computers with access to rockauto.com at
home you carried around in your pocket
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers the
rockauto.com catalog is unique and very
easy to navigate you can see all the
parts available for your vehicle you can
choose the brand specifications prices
that you prefer
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always low for everybody why spend up to
twice as much for the same parts and
also for our worst selection
amazing selection reliability prices all
the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck and as always write walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
misanthrope says would matt walsh
criticize ted cruz more if cruz had
called parents at a school board meeting
terrorists for their conservative
beliefs
we all know the answer to that question
shame on walsh for his lack of
consistency in being weak because
knowles and cruz probably told him to
defend cruz and not cancel the traitor
well you're right knowles uh instructed
me to defend ted cruz and i said yes sir
mr knowles as as you wish
but to answer your question yes i would
criticize him a lot more if he called
parents at school board meetings
terrorists in fact i would just
criticize them that's a deal breaker
without even having to think about it
that's you're you're done as far as i'm
concerned that is that's that is
irredeemable
to call parents at school board meetings
terrorists
but i don't react that way to this
because the the
what you mentioned calling parents at
school board meetings terrorists that
would be a far more egregious and
harmful thing to say far more
the january 6th rioters
rioters and they were also absolute
abject morons who did something
self-destructive
and politically and personally suicidal
and now we all have to deal with the
consequences of that forever
as the left exploits it to no end
i said this at the time when it was
happening
that these people are doing something
that the rest of us are going to have to
live with forever
congratulations guys
you were feeling angry you were overly
emotional and you wanted to
vent your frustration now the rest of us
have to deal with it forever
now that doesn't make them terrorists
it just makes them rioters
and there's certainly a big difference
which is why i would never call them
terrorists and i and i object to that
categorization
and i object to ted cruz saying he
shouldn't have said it
but
they're not on the same playing field as
parents who are attending school board
meetings to complain about the
curriculum
so um
you know yes we don't want to go
we don't want to to adopt the left's
playbook
of course with this and guys start
talking about terrorism and interaction
because that's just not true it's not
factually true
terrorism has a definition it's not that
an insurrection has a definition it's
not that
as we've discussed many times this was
not an effort
to actually overthrow the us government
there certainly was never any chance of
that happening and that's that's not
actually what these people were
intending to do pretty pretty clear
because once they got in the building
they just kind of wandered around and
took some selfies and left
um
so we we can make that point but the two
things that you're you you're trying to
equate i i find that totally absurd
all right history and headlines says how
concerned are you that you cannot say
honest statements without fear of being
banned harassed etc uh i'm not very
concerned about it honestly
you can't worry about that i'm just
going to continue
saying what is true
and uh what happens happens
now you can't get to the point you've
got to be smart about it
because i think being able to use these
platforms these platforms can be a
powerful tool
so you don't want to just jump on a
grenade for no reason
you know you don't want to you don't
want to self-immolate for no reason
um
so you want to be a little bit smart in
how you navigate these things but if you
get to the point where you abandon the
truth entirely and you say i'm not going
to say the truth anymore cause i'll get
kicked off the platform well there's no
point anymore there's no point even
having the platform or the only point at
that point is your own
you know just your own personal brand
your own profit
and uh that cannot be our primary
concern
ljy says matt why are you still on
twitter disappointed you don't just give
up the platform
yeah i really don't understand this
point of view
you're certainly not the only person to
say that to me i really don't understand
it
if i'm able to use the left's platform
against them
why wouldn't i
now as i said if it gets to a point
where you simply cannot use the platform
at all
while still speaking the truth well then
forget about it
but as long as it's possible to use
these platforms against them
and to use it to get the the truth out
and get the message out
and to mobilize people
um why wouldn't you do it
i mean just one example
the the movement at school boards
mobilizing parents at school boards
that was organized largely through
social media and largely not you know
not not through the kind of conservative
social media platforms but through the
left-wing social media platforms like
facebook and
twitter now those platforms didn't like
the fact that we were using the platform
in that way but we were able to so
what's the downside
i mean i'm all about if you want to go
use alternative platforms but but
abandoning
the most powerful invisible platforms
just in protest to me doesn't make any
sense because that's what they want you
to do i can tell you twitter
as far as i'm concerned not that they're
sitting around worried specifically
about me all the time but i but if they
had a choice like they would much prefer
for me not to use the platform and
people like me
so am i going to give them what they
want
until they force my hand no i'm not
going to
um pig venus
i don't know what that's supposed to
mean says thank you for not calling the
guy she or her it's ridiculous
well listen pig venus if i ever do that
if i if you ever hear me using the
preferred pronouns
calling a a a man a she
what i want you to do is grab the
nearest hammer and beat me with it until
i'm dead that's what i want
might be a little bit extreme but that's
at the very least stop listening to my
show stop taking anything i say
seriously if you ever catch you won't
ever catch me doing that but if i do
that's like invasion of body snatchers
my mind is gone
abandon all hope
okay that's how strongly i feel about
that
uh tupac tupac lives says
world's leading children's lgbt author
dude that is not funny anymore you ran
that joke into the ground real quick
also that book is not as hilariously
clever as you think neither are you
first of all it's extremely funny still
for sure uh second it's not a joke it's
it's literally just a fact
i am quite literally by definition
the leading lgbt author and voice in the
country
i don't know what you want me to tell
you that's just that's it
and uh finally is matt's background just
an image
well let's find out
i think so yeah actually it is it's just
a it's just a screen
this is this is like the moment in the
truman show where he runs into the
horizon and finds out it's just a big
giant dome so i know it's very
disheartening for a lot of you uh
actually like i said we changed studios
so uh
we're building a real one i'm told but
for right now i have a just a screen
behind me
so there are other clues as well like
that that banjo back there
we gave that banjo away and yet it
appears again
so
in fact what we we went away on
christmas break and uh what i was told
was when i get back to the studio
there's gonna be a like a brand new
studio built it's gonna be great and
wonderful and i was looking forward to
it and then i got here you know starting
the new year and i walk in and uh oh no
it's just the old studio but this time
in the form of a sheet
so
still waiting on that real one if you
haven't heard of jonathan isaac yet then
you might be living under a rock i mean
get with the time you lose her the nba
star stood strong with his values while
everyone else kneeled and faced heavy
criticism from the media for his views
on social issues and vaccines over the
past few years which is why i'm very
excited to announce that he's decided to
write a book with the daily wire uh
which is called why i stand jonathan's
book will be about his rise in his
basketball career his journey into faith
and his strength of character to stand
alone in the face of immense pressure
check out the teaser
the orlando magic's 23 year old starting
forward is deeply religious and proudly
unvaccinated on friday isaac got
attention for choosing not to kneel in
unison with his teammates or to wear a
black lives matter shirt my name is
jonathan isaac i play for the orlando
magic
and i'm writing a book with the daily
wire
[Music]
courage does not mean the absence of
fear and in today's day there are so
many things that you can be afraid of
facing because of believing what you
believe or deciding to stand for what
you believe in and i believe this book
gives you a blueprint of my story of how
christ has made the difference in my
life from a young kid who struggled with
fear anxiety
self-insecurity to a man willing to
stand for what he believes
[Music]
jonathan's book will be one of the first
under the daily wires new publishing arm
dw books and we couldn't be happier to
have him on board the book is available
for pre-order now at amazon so reserve
your copy today let's get down to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
sticking with the theme of mass
formation psychosis today we cancel la
times columnist and somehow pulitzer
prize-winning writer michael hilsick
for this piece recently published by the
times titled
mocking anti-vaxxer's covet deaths is
ghoulish yes but may be necessary
now that title is pretty bad but it's
actually slightly an improvement over
the original option the url for the
article indicates that it was first
posted with this title
why shouldn't we dance on the graves of
anti-vaxxers
well anybody anybody with a soul can
immediately think of probably a dozen
reasons off the top of the head
why you shouldn't do that but hilsick
has not been burdened with a human soul
which enabled him to write this quote
among all the ways that covenanting
affects our lives the pandemic confronts
us with a profound moral dilemma
how should we react to the deaths of the
unvaccinated
again that's not a dilemma at all for
any morally decent human being that's a
dilemma in the same way that like
should i kill and eat my neighbor is a
dilemma if you find yourself needing to
pause for even a moment to consider the
question that's a bad sign
for both you and your neighbor anyway
hiltzek continues on the one hand a
hallmark of civilized thought is the
sense that every life is precious on the
other those who have deliberately
flouted sober medical advice by refusing
a vaccine known to reduce the risk of
serious disease from the virus including
the risk to others and end up in the
hospital of the grave can be viewed as
receiving their just desserts
needless to say
though both hate speech and
misinformation are ostensibly banned
from twitter this article and its author
have not been removed from the platform
even though it commits both infractions
not only is he delighting in the death
of an entire group of people which i
would call hate speech
i don't know what hate speech is if it's
not that
but he's also making factually incorrect
statements about the vaccine
vaccinated and unvaccinated people both
spread the virus which means that the
unvaxed do not represent any special or
unique risk to others
if they're putting anybody at risk at
all it would be it would be themselves
which frames this entire column in an
even more sinister light continuing the
issue of how to think about the deaths
of the unvaccinated has been thrown into
high relief locally by the case of kelly
ernby a prominent orange county
republican and deputy district attorney
who advocated against vaccine mandates
and died of covet around new year's day
unvaccinated
so what then is the proper response to
the deaths of anti-vaxxers or other
determined foes of public health
first we must acknowledge that the
enemies needing to be stamped out are
misinformation lies and stupidity being
injected into the fight against covet
second we must view every one of these
deaths as a teachable moment
they demonstrate in the most vivid way
imaginable the folly of vaccine refusal
and a flouting
responsible public health measures they
underscore the dire consequence of
turning public health into a partisan
football
it may not be it may be not a little
ghoulish to celebrate or exalt in the
deaths of vaccine opponents and it may
be proper to express sympathy and
solicitude to those they leave behind
but mockery is not necessarily the wrong
reaction to those who publicly mocked
anti-covet measures and encouraged
others to follow suit before they
perished on the disease the dangers of
which they belittled there may be no
other way to make sure that the lessons
of these teachable moments are heard so
now may be a good time to show you what
our friend michael hilsick actually
looks like and here he is there in all
his glory as you can see he's both fat
and old so it's rather a bold move for
an elderly obese man to mock anyone for
dying
given that he's likely so near death
himself
also as the triple chin indicates he
doesn't take his own health nearly as
seriously as he pretends now normally i
would say that that his exorbitant waste
and his surplus of lard and chins is
none of my business
but because he's decided that other
people's medical decisions are his
business
it's fair to treat his medical decisions
as a public matter as well it's what he
wants apparently
now perhaps he would want us to mock his
death too when it comes sooner rather
than later
people who die of obesity have their own
choices largely to thank for it
can we make fun of them what about
promiscuous people who contract stds
say a prostitute who dies of hepatitis
what what about people who die for from
alcohol or drug abuse
is it necessary for the greater good
that we dance on the graves of all these
people
now i suppose hilsick would say no
that's different because the
unvaccinated pose a unique danger to
others
he would say that because he's a greasy
disgusting ugly liar
in reality as established the data
clearly proves that the unvaccinated are
not special drivers of the pandemic
everyone is spreading it
and even if they were primarily
responsible for spreading the virus
still to delight in the deaths of
ordinary people
mothers and fathers who leave children
and spouses behind
would be twisted and evil beyond words
but to gloat over their deaths when
their medical decisions had no special
impact on anyone but themselves
is a whole new level of deranged
it's clear in that case that you take
joy in their death and suffering
simply because you hate them
and you hate them not because they did
anything to you
but because they refused to comply with
your wishes and your demands they
belonged to the other group
you know they behaved in ways that you
found foreign and distasteful
they held opinions that you disagree
with and so you want them dead
you want their families ripped apart you
want their children to mourn them
now there's plenty of historical
precedent for this kind of bloodlust
towards the out group
and history teaches us that it leads
always and every time
to extraordinary suffering and misery
and violence
hiltic has aligned himself with quite
literally all of the worst people of
history
and he's not alone in that way of
thinking
which is the scariest thing of all
and it's why he is today finally
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
vladowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show california
considers universal health care and
doubling its taxes plus an la times
columnist makes the case for mocking
unbaxed americans who die of coven
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen